good morning guys in a new neighborhood
and no i'm not buying a new forever home
you guys are hilarious i love you guys
um my dad actually
decided that he wants to move to vegas
now which is interesting because just a
few months ago
he was asking are you going to stay in
vegas because if you are i want to move
and i told them realistically speaking i
don't know right now i'm in the
honeymoon phase of course i love
everything about vegas right anything
you're new with for the first six months
to a year you're gonna love it you love
your new car you love your new clothes
i'm like let me live here for a year
and once i stop mooning about everything
i get the real feel of vegas i'll let
you know if i love it or not i want to
be realistic before i uproot my dad and
he's like okay
but over the last couple of months
my dad
told me and he realized that he just
can't live without seeing me and taika
and i was like oh because i am his only
son
and you know my parents are divorced so
i'm like okay cool fine if you want to
move
then let's get your house so today i'm
on a search for a bunch of new houses
again for my dad
and uh this neighborhood looks quite
nice
i like it
it's i think it's my dad's style where
it's like super chill it's a gated
community
so it feels safe
it's already unlike the street that my
dad lives on where there's
a hell of cars going back and forth
random stray dogs
barking like crazy
low riders you catch my drift of where
my dad lives so this already feels
really nice let's go inside and take a
look all right so i'm inside now we got
what i believe is the living room
yeah there's like a living room here
we got
big matt vincent over there he comes
with the house
he's my official measuring tape
so we got the kitchen over here it's
actually kind of slimmer to my dad's
house actually the one he lives in now
this is the primary bathroom actually
okay so this is like a the master yeah
the master master
dad
oh if he wants to bring his ladies over
we got double sinks
got a little closet action
interesting
what is this
what makes people want to pick stuff
like this i think the year 1990.
it's actually built in 2001 but
all right i didn't know people are such
fan of finches
or hummingbirds oh hummingbirds yeah i
think they're hummingbirds
all right in the kitchen now
we got oh cool inside washer and dryer
that's always convenient
because my dad's washer and dryer is in
the garage right now but now to keep
everything inside
guest bathroom
was this the garage
two-car garage that works
that's pretty cool and a fan and a fan
a weird silly family
for all those illegal poker games
yeah which yeah what's going on here
yeah it's crazy
look at this two-tone
and they got windows and we just are
those windows boarded up windows
another bedroom
interesting two stories with only two
bedrooms
i rarely see that
a two-story two-bedroom home
usually you only need one story for that
that's what the backyard looks like i
can't really see
i like the backyard
feels very cozy and quaint and i could
just see tyka like coming out of there
visiting my pops riding his little bike
his little scooter around my dad just
chilling there watching him having a
good time it's kind of cuny
yeah the only problem is this is a
two-story so it fits within our price
range but
my dad doesn't want to go up and
downstairs because he is older so i'm
gonna have to look at some other ones
cool at the next house
i already like this area because this
one is close to spring valley it's
actually considered in the spring valley
community which means it's next to
chinatown and that makes me happy
because my dad loves chinese markets
getting his groceries and stuff like
that but more importantly
my dad likes activity so
right now living in l.a he'll go get the
chinese newspaper every day from the
local chinese liquor store and i'm like
dad you know i can set up a subscription
for you so it just lands at your front
door but he's like no i like
going out and about and getting things
and running my errands because it keeps
them busy and it keeps them active so
having a house in this area seems pretty
damn cool the only problem is chinatown
is a little bit further from where i
live in vegas so it's i'm trying to
decide like what would be better would
it be better for my dad to live closer
to me in case anything happens i can get
to him real quick or if he lives in
chinatown and his daily life is that
much better the good thing is
vegas
is not that big like it's pretty much
only 20 30 minutes from one side all the
way to the other so at the end of the
day none of it is that bad but if i can
choose i'm still trying to figure out if
i should put my dad closer to all the
fun asian stuff or closer to me
cool walking into the house whoa this
thing's pretty big
i didn't realize how big this was
so there's a family room here
and then it goes all the way down there
wow
so we got a cool little kitchen
i feel like my dad likes this
like 90s 2000 style
and then he can
cook
hang out here
smells like incense in here huh yeah
so that tells me the previous owners are
probably chinese and buddhists or
vietnamese and buddhists
but i think my dad would like this it's
pretty chill
nice and open yeah it also reminds me of
the house that i uh i grew up in as a
kid
when i on my parents were still together
i'm just kidding
go checking out the master bedroom
walking through here oh good size
seems like everyone got double sinks
that's pretty cool
come in here
it's pretty big
big size master
computers
oh i think they see it changed
go through here
and then i'm sorry
so we got one more master
assume that's the garage
and then we got wait that's garage what
the hell this thing
closet
makes sense
and then over here we got another
bedroom
okay
i like that it doesn't have that popcorn
ceiling which means it's somewhat modern
and then here's another one
shirt bathroom
indoor laundry cool another one
it's nice
this is a good house good sized house
i like it
so even though this house is in a gated
community
my agent didn't point out something
where at the front gate the gate closed
immediately after one car came in
and then also there's a metal gate here
and also there's a metal gate back there
so
security might be an issue here and also
the gate code that she was issued they
said that they change it every three
days
so
safety is also really important for my
dad so she's actually gonna
cross-reference this neighborhood with
her police buddies to see what the crime
rate is around here because that's also
very very important
right so this is a pretty interesting
neighborhood it seems like all the
houses
are attached
so you'll see that both of these garages
share one wall
which
is a good and bad thing
good as in usually when the units are
attached like that it's cheaper
um the bad thing is a lot of people
don't like sharing a wall with the
neighbor
so i'll have to see so these guys are
joined by here
these guys are joined by here by the
garage so maybe that's
probably not much of a noise issue
because you're usually not loud in the
garage
but we'll go inside
and check it out what i do like though
that i see is there is a lot of parking
here
so if i were to come visit my dad
um that'll be easy to find parking
because
yeah there's actually parking along the
house too what about here
i guess just the driveway huh so yeah
i don't think this this isn't big enough
to park the car so yeah i would have to
park sideways that big old thing
the front is kind of cozy it's like
covered
right from the rain
and yes it does rain in vegas and you
got nice little shade you come in here
oh it feels kind of nice in here
it's pretty spacious too wow
it's a living room
oh and the kitchen's tucked away like
this
okay
this is old but it's in good condition
still
which is cool
smells freshly painted
we got how much is this house 360. 360.
see that was a good deal because a lot
of the other ones we're looking at were
mid to high force
so
looks like we're getting similar space
but since it's attached
then you get to save like
75 to almost 100 g's
on the house
we got
a bedroom up here
oh laundry yeah they've been doing
indoor laundry for a long time
l.a just got caught up with that
shirt bathroom
okay
let's see go this way
we came in through here
and then we got
a bedroom
master bedroom
damn they've been doing double sinks for
a long time huh
there's a lot of construction that la
just picked up like double sinks and
indoor laundry
i didn't see those when i used to go
house shopping with my mom
that's cool
you guys want to see something
interesting
when you come out
into the backyard you technically share
the backyard with everyone else
which is probably why you get the
savings
but if you don't care it doesn't matter
it's also just one giant block party out
here that's kind of cool light a bunch
of fireworks
hell yeah
[Music]
cool and the next house
this layout is kind of weird because you
come inside
and you see the living room which is
cool
but then the kitchen and the dining room
seems so removed
so it almost feels like if after you're
done cooking
and you're over here
sitting down even with your family
you're just kind of like in loner town
because usually people like to eat
be where the people are at watch tv
where the life is at
but the good side is there's no hoa in
this community
which is awesome because for someone
that's
retired like my pops
the minimal amount of repeat payments
the better
so that is a good point so
lots to consider
i like how everything is this wood floor
that's easy to clean
so we got valve's bedroom one bedroom
two bedroom three
damn lots of indoor laundry huh
now we're at this cute little house
it's pretty cool
it's not a gated community
so that does worry me a little bit
because safety is really important for
my pops
since he lives by himself and he is a
little bit older
um but we'll have to see and look at the
rest of the package the price and
everything to see if it's worth it
this part is uh within 10 minutes from
my house so i do like that
or if anything does happen you can call
me i could be here real quick especially
since there's no traffic in vegas
and that is interesting
it's just a plug oh that's for their
security camera
oh
hello
what is going on with these
half dome looking things
they really like that design in here
okay
34 still under four
2003 okay three bedrooms
a little kitchen action oh it's a good
sized backyard
for the size of the house hello
fire pit action
all right so come in
to the left is the living room and
kitchen
and this way
is
a bedroom
okay
[Applause]
oh no
now the cops are gonna come we'll get
arrested
that's modern
master
oh cool
oh this guy's a retired fat
that's pretty dope dude
and uh whoa look how tall these ceilings
are
what is this
office
with it was the previous owner a a
lawyer
it looks like one of those like
larry h parker commercials
what is that
is that to a bar
it's a big metal door
that's crazy
what is
this is crazy imagine i just buy this
for my dad and he's like why did you get
me this
what does it look like this
is wine yeah
interesting
because now it's all low here and it was
huge over there oh that makes sense
it's a cool little backyard
what is that kitty cats
it's a kitty cat house
no that's birds oh birds
it's gotta be a bird thing
i don't know oh yeah like chickens or
something huh
they also have chicken coops nice little
backyard they got little toys
and a roll-up door
security what what's on the other side
of the roll-up door look how big these
palms are this is so weird why is that
there why is it a roll-up door
maybe for shade
maybe they hate their neighbors or like
i'm tired of seeing you guys
i have a lot of questions and then you
just got a random doggy door
what all right
solar too yeah what an interesting house
a giant tall gate is mad six feet tall
oh yeah an electric
roll
awning
the
door
that metal interior chicken coop
looks like it's like going into like a
bank vault i know what the heck
this place is weird
that's crazy all right let's check out
the bedrooms i bet it's even weirder
i feel like the bedrooms would be here
or something okay now it's normal
let's see
got one of these half doors again
okay
what do you got in here
guest room
nothing
whoa look at that crazy sink
interesting style
very interesting those light fixtures
are just like melt like the glasses
okay all right where's the this is the
master
oh so the doggy door goes straight to
the
master
they must really like their animals
state-of-the-art
and then
interesting
do you like a trip to the tropics
what a shame look look at how nice this
driveway is
it looks nice outside nice bushes
the neighborhood is super nice
it just so happens the inside is the
weirdest house we've ever seen so far
super quiet neighborhood yeah it's
quieter too
it's not so busy like you know how some
of those other streets that we were in
it just seemed like the truth is like if
you wanted to
modernize and remodel the inside of that
place you could do
yeah it's not crazy it's just a lot of
cosmetic that's it yeah yeah layout's
good but it's also work i don't want to
do
it's also work i don't want to do it i
don't have time to do it
or my dad doesn't want to do either you
were bringing a hamburger
or my dad might paint the inside mint
chip ice cream anyways or just do part
of the outside mint chip yeah
cool last house of the bunch
and i do like the outside it's very
peaceful
roads are nice and smooth looking
we'll take a look
two bedrooms how much was this one again
350 350 okay
bedroom one two bedrooms
and two baths okay
this is a bedroom or is this considered
like an office
office
office done okay
cool
and then we got
laundry
[Music]
kitchen
it's cool got tall ceilings
and then hello
are you giving a report on the
so if you don't house this house i have
other houses for you to look at oh smart
mls
nice
over here we got
oh that's pretty nice
tall ceilings
master
oh a jacuzzi
dump
oh hidden basket
[Music]
nice it's pretty
yeah
nice
so i think the last house is actually it
which is ironic because it's the last
house but it also just got listed today
so we don't know what the activity is
don't know if it's going to turn into a
bidding war
when it comes to buying houses there's a
lot of complications it's not just
here's the price and you go okay i'll
pay that price
and um and you get it you know because
the price is actually pretty competitive
i think it's 350 360 which is exactly
within our budget
and uh
but we don't the market has slowed down
from the summer which is good for us
so we'll have to see um the real estate
agent christina is going to run a bunch
of comps meaning comparables to see um
what the actual price range should be
because you don't want to come in too
much above because what happens is when
you're getting a loan from the bank if
it's more than what the house is valued
at the bank gets scared to loan you that
full sum of money so whatever it is
above
you have to cover that so for example
like let's say the house is only worth
200 but the price is 300 and the bank's
like well it's appraised for 200 so even
though the bidding work got all the way
up to 300 i'm gonna give you a 200 g
loan you're gonna have to cover the
other 100 g's by yourself
and that's always kind of risky so we
still got to do a lot of back end work
but this will be
um
one of the homes we put an offer in
for so
we'll see across our fingers and maybe
we'll get it